one and a half centuries ago Civil War
divided these United States of America
yet in its wake we would have needle as
one nation indivisible during the bloody
year of his Gettysburg Address President
Lincoln chartered the National Academy
of Sciences comprised of 50
distinguished American researchers whose
task was then as now to advise Congress
and the executive branch of all the ways
the frontier of science may contribute
to the health wealth and secured its
residents
as a young nation just before score and
seven years old we had plucked the
engineering fruits of the industrial
revolution that transformed Europe but
Americans had yet to embrace the meaning
of science to society now with more than
2,000 members the National Academy
encompasses dozens of fields on dreamt
about the time of Lincoln's charter
quantum physics discovered in the 1920s
now drives nearly one-third of the
world's wealth forming the basis for our
computer revolution in the creation
storage and retrieval of information and
as we continue to warm our planet
climatologist avis from ourselves
during the centennial of its charter
President Kennedy addressed the Academy
membership noting the range and depth of
scientific achievement in this room
constitutes the seedbed of our nation's
future
in this the 21st century innovations and
science and technology form the primary
engines of economic growth while most
remember honest aid for war and peace
slavery and freedom the time has come to
remember him for sending our nation on a
course of scientifically enlightened
governance without which we all may
perish from this earth
you